[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER SANSON: All right.
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our talk today.
We're going to talk about
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery solutions
for hybrid and
multi-cloud customers.
We're very excited to have you
here again on day two of Next,
and for sticking with us.
Yesterday, if you
happened to catch it,
we did a talk on
CI/CD for serverless.
That was focused on sort
of cloud-native, modern,
serverless applications
and infrastructure.
This one is sort of
kind of the opposite.
This one is focused on
large enterprises, companies
who are living in
sort of a world
where you have on-prem
applications as well as cloud,
and you have different services
running on multiple clouds,
and kind of some
of the challenges
that may present
around developer
tooling in those ecosystems.
So this is a stat that Urs
actually shared yesterday
from RightScale.
80% of enterprises are adopting
a hybrid multi-cloud strategy.
And I think there's
a lot of talk
over time around different
words around cloud-native
and Tier 1 and Tier
2 and lift-and-shift
and all these different terms.
And I think the world
that we've arrived at now
is that this is just
kind of the new normal
for a lot of different reasons,
whether it's cost or control
or not really seeing the
benefit to moving quite yet.
And also sort of
leveraging the best
aspects of the different
cloud providers.
Increasingly, enterprises
are adopting strategies
where they're deploying
different services
to different places,
and there's a lot
of challenges
between interacting
between on-prem
resources and the cloud.
So what do we mean by
hybrid and multi-cloud?
It's one of those words,
kind of like "serverless,"
kind of like "DevOps," that
depending on who you ask
and what time of day
it is, you probably
get a different definition.
I think the first thing
that comes to mind
is running applications.
So we've had a bunch
of announcements
so far around GKE On-Prem,
serverless, things like that.
And that's often where
your mind goes first.
You think about applications,
so running Kubernetes on-prem,
running Kubernetes
on Kubernetes Engine,
or running it on other clouds.
And for that, if you've
sort of looked at Google
or been in the space
long, you might
be familiar with Spinnaker.
Spinnaker is our open-source,
multi-cloud, continuous
delivery platform that we
co-develop with Netflix.
So Netflix started this.
It's what they use for all
their continuous delivery.
And there are some
other talks that
are going to be really focused
really explicitly on this.
Target is giving a
talk this afternoon,
that should be really great,
about how they use Spinnaker
to deploy to both their on-prem
retail stores and the cloud.
And it's really set up for
sort of complex sequencing
and rollout orchestration.
So these are just kind
of all the different use
cases, though, that often fall
under the hybrid umbrella.
As we talk to customers
and we say, well,
what do you mean by hybrid?
We get all sorts of
different answers.
So things around multi-cloud
deployment, edge computing,
invoking legacy dependencies.
But for today,
we're going to focus
on largely the context of CI,
and continuous integration.
So for CI workloads,
they look a lot different
than running
applications, right?
They're sort of more batch-like.
You have to deal with
things like configuration
management, peak workloads,
multiple platforms, things
like that.
And what we find is that a lot
of companies who have on-prem
build dependencies-- so
things like GitLab or GitHub
Enterprise or Bitbucket
Enterprise or On-Prem
Artifactory-- at
build time, you need
to be able to securely
access these resources so
that you can actually
build and test your code.
The problem is that, because
these things are on-prem,
you need to securely
access them,
you are now sort
of in the business
of having to run your
own CBOT CI server farm.
If everything is in the
cloud, then of course
you can use a
cloud-hosted solution
and offload a lot of that
management and architecture
to someone else.
But the problem is that if
any one of these things--
source code, artifacts,
other things like databases
and license servers--
are on-prem, then your CI server
needs to be on-prem as well.
And as we talk to customers,
really what they kind of want
is something like this.
They don't really want
to necessarily have
to move their source
code to the cloud.
They don't want to have to
sort of move license servers
to the cloud.
Or maybe they just can't,
with the way their company
is set up.
But they would love
to be able to offload
all of that infrastructure,
and that they're
investing too many
resources in order
to scale up to the number of
builds that they're running.
So we're going to talk a
little bit about that today.
One of the announcements
earlier today--
oh.
And so one of the
takeaways, I think,
is that you can use managed
CI with on-prem resources.
And we're going to give
a demo a little bit
later and talk about some new
solutions for Google Cloud
about how this is possible.
If you were at the
keynote this morning,
you saw one of the announcements
that we're really excited about
is around Knative.
So if you are in the
category where you're
running workloads on-prem
and on top of Kubernetes,
this is a new series of
open-source components
that adds a new
layer of primitives
on top of Kubernetes, one of
which is called Knative Build.
And that lets you--
is more of a
first-class way to find
builds that can run
on top of Kubernetes.
But for our talk, we're
going to focus on, how can I
offload this all together?
So before we jump
into that, I want
to do a quick little story.
And this is going
to be interactive.
I'm going to describe
some of the conversations
we had with a customer about
their current situation.
And if anyone can sort
of guess who this is,
I want you to please feel
free to raise your hand,
shout it out, take a wild guess.
There are no wrong answers.
So this company had a
self-hosted CI system,
and they had a couple
developer teams
who were building software.
And they were running tests
on their local workstation,
and they were building
software, and that
was kind of working fine.
But after a while, they
were having trouble.
They were having inconsistent
build environments.
They were getting
weird irregularities
between their workstations.
And so they decided, hey, let's
set up a dedicated CI server.
So they set up a CI server farm.
They installed Jenkins,
or something like that,
and sort of wrapped
it with things
like events and workflow.
And out the other side, they
would have things like logs
and build artifacts.
And this worked pretty
well for a while.
And other companies and
teams inside the organization
said, hey, this is looking
actually pretty good.
We want to get in on this.
So they started saying, could
we use the same CI system?
And so they joined.
And they started sending
even more builds.
And what happened is that
the more builds they sent,
they started running
into problems,
things like bottlenecks,
things like queuing.
And so they said,
hey, you know what?
We should get a dedicated
team that can handle this.
So maybe it's
somebody on the team.
Maybe it's a new dedicated team.
But someone said, hey,
you're responsible now
for making sure that
this thing is working
and that our developers can
continue iterating on code.
And this worked
pretty well, too.
But the company kept growing,
and the team kept growing,
and so they kept
sending more builds.
And this introduced new issues.
They were building all sorts
of new, different types
of applications.
So they kind of continued
to grow the team.
And around this time,
they said, you know, this
is kind of actually
like a formal job.
So we should sort of
give this team a name.
So we called it the Platforms
team, or the Tools team,
or the Ops team.
And they were really
responsible for building out
this infrastructure
for the developers.
And they said, you
know, not only can we
actually manage our
machines, but we can actually
add a lot of value here.
So we could do
things like provide
more logic around releases and
rollouts, things like Canaries.
We can do things like
security and analytics,
so that we can measure things
like mean time to release,
improve over time.
And management said, you
know, that sounds actually
like a pretty good idea.
So we grew that
team a little bit.
So that kept growing.
But the company kept growing.
We kept adding more developers.
We kept adding more builds.
And at this point in
time, they said, gee,
it looks like we've
actually built
an entire CI/CD infrastructure.
We should give
this thing a name.
So we call it the thing
like the Accelerator,
or the Pipeline Factory,
or something like that.
And they sort of productize
that internally, present it
to developers, and
sort of say, you know,
you don't need really
to think about this.
This is kind of our own
little internal CI product.
So the team grew even more.
But what happened is
this kind of never ended.
The team kept growing.
The builds kept coming.
And the builds, they
just-- the problem
is they never
really stop, right?
So what we found is that,
in talking to customers,
the number of builds and
tests that they're running
are actually growing
superlinearly
to the size of their team.
So if their engineering
team is kind
of going like this, because of
modern best practices like CI,
their build volume is actually
kind of going like this.
And what's happening is
that you're constantly
racing against time.
And so you could sort of see the
trend line, where it's going.
And your infrastructure
is just keeping up
with the amount of
builds that you can do.
And what we found is that
customers are actually
doing kind of crazy things.
They're actually doing
things like throttling
the number of builds
that their developers run
by not adding new features.
So they're sort of
discouraging builds
because the infrastructure
can't really handle it.
All right.
So who was it?
Anyone have any guesses?
[INAUDIBLE]?
Let me ask it this way.
Does this sound like
any of you here?
Yeah, it's everybody.
This is everybody.
Everybody has gone through this.
There's a Googler, he calls
this the Rube Goldberg Machine
builder problem.
So if you're familiar with
Rube Goldberg machines,
we basically keep
building machines
that build other machines.
And it starts innocently
enough, right?
You're like, oh, I need
to run a couple builds.
Oh, I need to run
a couple triggers.
Oh, now I want to
get some metadata,
and I want to do
some more workflow.
And before you know it,
you've reinvented the wheel
and you've created a whole
CI/CD infrastructure.
And yes, Google was
absolutely a right answer.
We're no exception.
Back in 2015, we were
running 800,000 builds a day.
In 2018, that number is
already up to 4 million.
Our engineering team has
not grown at this same pace.
And honestly, this number
continues to go up today.
And that's because
the builds never stop.
We don't see this trend
ending any time soon.
We have things like now
ML workloads, and IoT,
and serverless.
And the number of
builds and tests
are just going to continue
to grow faster and faster.
So this is kind of the first
takeaway of our talk today,
is that CI, I think
fundamentally,
is a compute problem.
We tend to think of it as
kind of a workflow problem.
It's like, oh, if I can
write just the right number
of scripts, and automate
them in just the right way,
I can run CI/CD.
And that's absolutely true.
The problem is that
you then actually need
to run those
workloads somewhere.
And CI compute looks
really different.
It's batch workloads.
It's configuration management.
It's crazy things like
nested virtualization.
And this has a real cost to it.
So McKinsey did a
recent study and found
that application developers
spend a third of their time
as system engineers.
So this is things like debugging
builds, standing up servers.
I don't know, has anyone
here ever kind of upgraded
the version of Jenkins that
was running and just completely
wiped out their entire system?
Yeah.
Yeah, I have.
So how can we sort
of move past this?
So if we look back
at our diagram
here, a lot of customers
that we talk to say,
there's a lot of value that
we're bringing to our company
around kind of the
releases and rollouts
and the product itself.
But this whole middle area
of machine management, we'd
really love to
move to the cloud.
We'd like to offload
all of this and just
stop having to think about it.
And then that lets
us get back to things
that really are more important.
So things like improving
our mean time to release,
reducing vulnerabilities,
keeping our company out
of the headlines with
downtime and things like that.
So the good news is
that we're here to help.
And we're introducing
this week Cloud Build.
So this was announced yesterday.
It's a hosted CI/CD platform for
increasing developer velocity,
so that you and your teams can
develop more quickly and more
safely.
So as a brief history, we
launched this a year ago
as Container Builder.
Container Builder was a hosted
solution to build Docker images
and push them up to Container
Registry in a safe and reusable
way.
And our vision for this was
always a little bit grander.
We realized that not only
can we build containers
using this approach,
but we can do things
like build tarballs
and binaries and run
sort of different tasks.
And you could point it out
at Git Repository, set up
a trigger so that when
you did a git push,
it would automate that for you.
With the Cloud
Build announcement
today, we have a couple features
as well that we're announcing.
The first is that you'll
notice that this is now
top level in the Cloud Console.
So if you go to the Cloud
Console, under Tools,
you'll now see Cloud Build.
We added support for
first-class artifacts,
so the same way you can build
and push images and associate
that with your builds, you
can now build other artifacts,
like binaries and
tarballs as well,
and push those up
to Cloud storage.
We also added support
for file path triggers,
and this lets you
filter your triggers
based on certain files
or subdirectories that
have changed.
And we have two other features
in private alpha right now.
They're going to be coming soon.
One is a much deeper
integration with GitHub.
So we're adding native
support for pull requests,
posting status back
to the Checks API
that they just
recently announced,
as well as creating triggers
programmatically via the API.
And the last is a
brand-new results
UI that we demoed
yesterday, that
helps developers debug
builds faster and get
more of a dashboard-like
view over their projects.
So this all sounds
great, Christopher,
but I kind of
thought the talk was
about hybrid and multi-cloud.
This doesn't really help me.
This is still a
cloud-hosted service.
I still have fundamental
security issues
about it interacting
with on-prem resources.
So today, we're also excited
to announce something else--
Cloud Build Custom Workers.
So Cloud Build Custom Workers
is a new feature of Cloud Build.
It's in early access right now.
It's going to be available soon.
And what it does is
it lets you securely
connect Cloud Build workers
to your on-prem resources.
So let's take a little bit of
a look at how this actually
works.
So this is my GCP project here.
And the way Cloud
Build works today
is that from my GCP project, I
request a build to Cloud Build.
Cloud Build then
actually runs that build
on a worker VM, which is
just a Google Compute Engine
VM in a shared pool
that we manage,
and run every build on a new VM.
So you send us a build request.
We grab one of the VMs from the
worker pool, run your build,
and then spin it down.
And so every build runs
on its own machine,
so it's completely
isolated and secure.
The problem is that,
in an on-prem scenario,
you're behind some firewall or
private network restrictions.
So when that worker goes to
access your source code or push
to a registry, it can't.
It hits the firewall,
doesn't have permissions.
So that's not going to work.
So we needed to
do something else.
So with Custom Workers,
instead of running
builds on a shared worker
pool up in the cloud,
we're going to run workers
inside of a GCP project
that you own and control,
and run builds there.
Now, because this is
running in your GCP project,
you can use VPC, or
virtual private cloud,
to connect that project
to your private network
through peering or sharing.
And now that worker can
securely talk to and access
your on-prem resources.
And what's really great
to realize about this
is that this is still
a managed service.
So these workers,
these GCE VMs that
are running inside your project,
you have complete control over.
You can access, you can
delete, you can configure.
But they're completely
managed by Cloud Build.
So you just tell us how big your
pool size you want it to be,
what kind of machine
type you use,
and Cloud Build will still
be responsible for delegating
builds to it, spinning up new
VMS, maintaining that pool,
managing the pool size,
making sure that it's
up, ready, and available.
So let's actually
see this in action.
So we're going to jump over
to a demo for a second.
Thank you.
And so for this instance, we've
set up two projects in GCP.
So the first project
is my on-prem project.
And inside of this
project, I have
installed a GitLab instance.
So I'm running a
self-hosted instance
of GitLab, where I have my
source code in my repository.
I then have a separate GCP
project for my Custom Worker
pool.
And inside of this
Custom Worker pool,
I'm going to use VPC peering
to set up a secure connection.
So this is my network
that I've created.
It's called My Network.
And I connected it to
my GCP on-prem project.
And if I go over to my
GCP on-prem project,
and I look at the
VPC network there,
we'll see that I've
created its equivalent,
so that now these two
networks are securely
talking to each other.
And if I go back to my
Custom Worker project
here, and look under
Compute Engine,
we'll see our worker pool.
So these are GCE
worker VMs that have
been spun up and managed
by Cloud Build inside
of your project.
So we should be good to go here.
So if I go over
to our repository
here, so this is
our GitLab repo,
we have a pretty simple
application set up.
We have a simple Ruby app.
And let's just go in and make an
arbitrary change to our Docker
file.
So I'm going to
commit that change.
And then if I go back to my
project and look at Cloud Build
here, we should see
that a new build
has successfully kicked off.
If I jump in here,
this is our build,
and we're going to
run a few steps here.
So these are build steps.
This is the Cloud
Build convention
for running sort of jobs or
tasks as part of your build.
And if we step through
these, we're going to--
oop, it's already done.
It's pretty fast.
Runs on Google network.
We're going to fetch
credentials from cloud storage.
We're going to decrypt
those credentials
with the built-in integration
with KMS, which is Google's
key management service.
We're then going to
configure Git, do a git
clone to fetch our source
code from the repo,
and then build our image
and push it to the registry.
And that all works pretty well.
And the way that
we wired this up
is we use Cloud Functions to act
as a bridge between the source
repo event and the actual
invocation of the build.
So if we go over
to Cloud Functions
as well in our
project, we previously
had set up this function.
So this function listens for
webhook events from GitLab
and then runs a build.
And so these are the same
build steps that we just saw.
We fetch credentials,
we build the image,
and we push it to the registry.
And if we go back over to GitLab
and look at our integrations,
we'll see that we had previously
set up a webhook pointing
at that Cloud Function.
So now every time we make a
change and we do a push or tag
or do a merge event,
it'll send that webhook up
to our Cloud Function.
The Cloud Function will
hear it, kick off the build,
and run it on Cloud Build.
So that was great.
But we haven't actually
shown this running
on our custom workers.
This would roughly look the
same if you were running it
on the shared pool.
So let's actually split this
out and do these side by side.
So this is our worker pool here.
And if we jump back
over to our project
here and go to our functions,
let's kick off a few builds
and see this happening.
So I'm going to
run a couple tests.
One, two, let's say four builds.
And go back to our
workers, and refresh here.
We should see, and
sure enough, our builds
are running on our
custom worker pool.
And if we keep refreshing,
we should ultimately
get to around four new VMs.
And so what's happening
is that Cloud Build
has sent the build to
one of our GCE workers.
And now it's in the background,
spinning up a new VM
to replace it so that the
next build that comes in,
the VM is pre-warmed
and ready to go.
And if we keep
refreshing this, we'll
see this sort of
happen over time.
And we're up to now, yeah,
our four VMs running.
And if we kept going
with this, we'd
eventually see that it
would go back down to five.
As those builds would
complete, the VMs
would just be picked off.
And if we go over
to our terminal
here, and do an API response
here, and hit our Git endpoint
for the worker pool, we
can see the configuration
that we had previously
used to set up our pool.
So again, this is
Custom Workers.
You are in full control
and you own this.
So this is the project that
we had invoked this in.
We set our worker count to five.
We're running in
multiple regions,
for redundancy reasons, running
on n1-standard-1 machines.
And we set up our
own private network.
Now, I really want to call out
a couple of the highlights here,
which I think are
particularly cool, even
outside of the on-prem stuff.
So this is all up to you.
So we set our
worker pool at five,
so that-- you know, for
the sake of the demo.
But this is really subject
to your own GCP quota.
You can set this to five.
You can set it to 500.
You can set it to 5,000.
It doesn't really matter.
It's going to work.
And the other part
is machine type.
So if you're familiar
with Cloud Build,
the shared pool that
we run builds on
are all n1-standard-1 machines,
and they're pre-warmed.
We do offer two higher CPU
machines, a high CPU eight
and a high CPU 32.
But they're not pre-warmed.
So you have to wait
for spin-up time,
and usually the beefier machine
kind of makes up for it.
But we hear
frequently from users
that they have
different requirements.
They want a machine
with more RAM.
They want a pre-warmed compute.
They may want, I
don't know, 64 cores.
Who knows?
So you can now completely
configure that yourself.
So any GCE VM machine
type that's available,
you can configure
for your pool, so you
have a pre-warmed
pool of any machine
type of any size you want,
that's dedicated just
for you and your builds.
So if we jump back over
to our project here,
we're going to show kind of
one more interesting thing.
So one of the things we hear
from customers a lot as well
is that, this is great, but
I'm not starting from scratch.
I already have a
CI system set up.
I'm using Jenkins.
I'm using Buildkite.
I built my own homegrown system.
Something like that.
And I really am sick and tired
of people trying to convince me
that I need to rewrite
the whole thing
and migrate this whole workload,
and I need to do it by Q4.
It's just not going to happen.
I still have a business to run.
So what's great is that
because Cloud Build is--
it's also kind of a
build-as-a-service-type
solution.
It has an API.
It works from the Cloud SDK.
And you can use it as well
from your existing CI setups
to simply offload the
build infrastructure piece.
So we're going to switch
to a different project
here, where we're using GitLab's
built-in CI/CD functionality.
So GitLab's really great.
It comes with a lot of
features, beyond just the source
repo, around
continuous integration
and continuous delivery.
And actually, I want
to give a shout out.
We worked closely
with GitLab on this.
I want to say thanks to
Joshua, Priyanka, and Sid,
who were really helpful in
helping set this all up.
But if we go in here and we
look at our GitLab CI file,
we can see that we
are building a Docker
image using what I
think is probably
the way the majority
of users do this,
which is running a CI runner--
probably a Kubernetes
instance running locally--
and doing a Docker
in Docker Build.
So for anyone doing
Docker builds this way,
you're probably aware of some
of the security limitations
around this.
So when you're doing
a Docker build,
you need access to the Docker
daemon, which gives you
root access, which is sort
of a fundamental security
risk, in that malicious code
can potentially take over
your node, break out of the box,
and introduce a lot of issues.
Now, we get it.
This is sort of the way
that most people do it
because the idea of creating
your own pool of isolated VMs,
and spinning up and spinning
down VMs, is a lot of work.
But if you're doing
Docker in Docker,
you're aware of some of the
latency and security issues.
So what we can do, with
a few lines of code,
is simply swap this out and
offload all of our builds
to Cloud Build.
So we have a merge request
already queued up for this.
So we're going to
jump over here.
And if we look at the
code changes that we made,
let's see how those
colors showed up.
Pretty good.
We'll see that we
removed the steps where
we're doing Docker log-in,
Docker build, and Docker push.
And we've replaced it with our
CloudBuild.YAML file, which is
the Cloud Build build config.
And we're going to
do the same steps.
We're going to do a Docker
log-in, Docker build,
and Docker push to the registry.
We're then going to submit the
build using the GCloud Build
Submit command.
And what this will do is
that this will move the job,
or the Docker build,
from our own CI runner
that we had to provision
and self-manage,
and over to Cloud Build.
So if we go over to our
pipelines and run it,
and we're on our Cloud
Build branch here,
this will kick off.
What's really great about
this is that, while this build
is running, you'll notice that
all the rest of my pipeline
hasn't had to change.
So all the things that I'm
going to do after my image gets
built-- things that
I'm doing in GitLab,
like checking code quality,
running container scans
and dependency scans--
just works as-is.
So with very
minimal change, I've
been able to offload a
ton of the work and effort
that I normally have to do
in order to get this set up.
So this is going to run through.
And if we wanted to
jump into as well,
we could see the logs here.
You can see the steps
that are running.
We're building the
image, pushing the image
to the registry.
And it successfully succeeded.
And this build, if we
refresh, should be done.
And we've moved on with
the rest of our pipeline.
And we can see our worker
pool is back down to five now.
And what this lets us do is go
back over to our own project,
and go ahead and actually
delete our CI runner
that we had previously set
up because we don't need it
anymore.
It's not our problem.
So if we switch back to
the presentation, let's
just sort of recap what we did.
We were able to spin down
our own Kubernetes cluster
for doing builds, offload that
to the cloud, and using VPC,
connect multiple GCP projects
to a private network,
and use a hosted build
infrastructure as a service.
So what are some of the
benefits of Custom Workers?
First, it's managed
infrastructure.
Cloud Build is managing and
provisioning this pool for you,
so you don't have
to worry about it.
The second, I think it's
highly configurable.
So we showed the API get call.
You can pick your
machine type here.
You can pick your pool size,
even configure your own network
settings.
And this is just the beginning.
Having dedicated
pools per customer
lets us do a lot of things
that, with shared pools,
aren't really feasible.
And already from the
EAP, we're getting
a lot of feedback around
possibilities here,
so things like caching images,
adding persistent disks,
letting you cache dependencies
on the worker ahead of time,
as opposed to fetching
them during builds,
to speed up builds.
Also things like supporting
multiple regions, restricted IP
ranges, things like that.
So a lot of this
is on our road map.
But it's definitely on
our radar, and something
we're hearing about
from customers
as an area of interest.
And the last is, we should
talk about pricing, I guess,
I suppose.
So this is metered billing.
And now, again, these are
Compute Engine VMs running
inside your GCP project.
So you pay for the
compute directly.
So whatever your
current agreement
is with Google for how you
pay for VMs, it's per minute,
and it's just subject to
the regular GCE usage.
And there's no
additional overhead.
So you pay for the GCE
VMs and storage costs,
and you basically get
Cloud Build for free.
So if we go back to
our diagram here,
and we sort of look
at what our goal was
that we were hoping
to achieve, we really
wanted to do
something like this.
We wanted our build
dependencies to stay on-prem,
and we wanted
continuous integration
to run in the cloud.
And I think we were able to
achieve that using Cloud Build.
And what's really great
is that, as we showed,
you don't actually have to
rewrite your whole entire CI
infrastructure.
So if you're currently running
on-prem CI with something
like Jenkins or TeamCity or you
wrote your own infrastructure
solution, you can
leverage Cloud Build
to replace your build
agents or your runners
in order to offload
that compute workload.
And because the worker is
running in an on-prem network,
you can now talk to resources
like repos and artifacts.
So one thing I do want to
touch upon before we go further
is how sort of Knative and some
of the other on-prem solutions
kind of work in this world.
So we talked a little
bit at the beginning,
but this is for
people who really
want to offload the workload.
If you really like the
idea of building out
your own infrastructure,
we definitely
recommend using
Kubernetes as sort
of an underlying component.
It deals with a lot
of the issues for you,
things like auto-scaling,
things like caching.
And if you take a
look at Knative,
you'll find some new
primitives that make it
even easier for you to do that.
So if we look at some of
our takeaways, two big ones.
CI is, I think, at the end of
the day, a compute problem.
I think anyone here
who has to manage it,
is on the hook for it,
knows that you spent some
nights and weekends
having to debug builds,
having to deal with
infrastructure.
You can see the trend line
and know that sort of you're
going to run out of
capacity by Q2 next year.
And that you need help.
So that's what we're here for.
And Cloud Build Custom Workers
is a really great solution
for enabling this.
And this is because, again,
the builds never stop.
So thank you very much.
That was the presentation.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]